in another move towards total and
complete authoritarianism the Trump
White House has gone completely back on
what White House press secretary Sean
Spicer previously said about blocking
media access and decided to block media
access to media outlets they don't like
at a recent gaggle in Sean Spicer's
office and we have the leaked audio
confirming the real goal here White
House press secretary Sean Spicer barred
reporters from a number of large media
outlets from participating in this
scheduled press gaggle on Friday as a
reminder two months ago in a panel
discussion Sean Spicer insisted that
open access for the media is quote what
makes a democracy a democracy versus a
dictatorship by his own definition doing
something that makes us more of a
dictatorship Sean Spicer said the
administration would also not be banning
individual outlets not long ago remember
this that I think that you're not that's
not going to happen well I think look
there's a big difference between a
campaign where it is paid it is a
private venue using private funds and a
government entity and I think we have a
respect for the press when it comes to
the government that that is something
that you can ban an entity from you know
conservative liberal or otherwise I
think that's what makes a democracy a
democracy verses or dictators flip-flop
doesn't matter trumpets don't care they
rationalize it because they believe
Trump that the media is really bad right
now folks tremendously bad look at who
was in and who was out of this
off-camera gaggle in Spicer's office out
Politico CNN New York Times BuzzFeed LA
Times Daily Mail well okay that one
maybe make sense the hill New York Daily
News and BBC AP and time boycott at the
gaggle in defense and solidarity with
the band outlets however a number of
right-wing propaganda news outlets
Breitbart one American news check that
one out by the way if you have the
tolerance for it the Washington Times
were in oh no it's not ideological on
the audio leaks which makes it
abundantly clear that certain media
outlets were intentionally excluded for
ideological reasons check it out our CNN
in the New York Times not in here right
now because you're unhappy with their
reporting why are they 9 because we had
a pool and then we expanded it we added
some folks to come cover but they're not
my decision to decide you know candidate
to expand the pool we're going to
aggressively push back we're just not
going to sit back and let you know false
narratives false stories and accurate
facts get out there and there it is this
is a push back against what they call a
false narrative and false stories this
is dangerous and I hate to tell you if
you're waiting around for the trumpet to
wake up and realize this is all an
authoritarian nightmare Pat you need to
stop waiting because it's not going to
happen some of them are what's called in
poker pot committed they've invested
enough in what's happening that they're
not getting out even if they're deep
down starting to have doubts and then
others are falling for the alternate
reality that Trump is built where you
can only trust him you need to be tough
with media bla bla bla this is how nuts
the situation is you gotta love house
Sean Spicer was trying to make it seem
like it was about semantics that they
weren't going to be able to fit all
those people in that room and then
eventually one pressed he got to the
real issue that he didn't want
misinformation to get spread out to the
public this is coming from Sean Spicer
the guy who started his his job as press
secretary by claiming that Oh Trump's
inauguration was the biggest in
presidential history yeah it's
absolutely pathetic and I like that that
reporter said but there's plenty of room
in here I mean it the office isn't even
nearly full and to further illustrate
how insane the situation is Fox News's
Shep Smith is again standing up to Trump
Fox News that's right that's what I said
saying CNN isn't fake news and the Trump
is still don't care a bizarre fact free
loyalty has been created by Trump that
somehow exceeding Fox News's right-wing
loyalty check this out this all came to
a head after a series of events first
CNN reported extensively on Trump
campaign official communications with
Russia then CNN reports the White House
chief of staff said administration
officials to talk to reporters off the
record right urging them to knock down
the Trump campaign and Russia
portes then this morning President Trump
again called the fake news media the
enemy of the people and railed against
fake news I want you all to know that we
are fighting the fake news it's fake
phony fake
a few days ago I called the fake dudes
the enemy of the people and they are
they are the enemy because they have no
sources they just make them up when
there are none he later said he was
referring to the Washington Post which
reports it had nine sources on his
report the president said flatly he
doesn't believe them
for the record fake news refers to
stories that are created often by
entities pretending to be news
organizations solely to draw clicks and
views inter-basin nothing of substance
in short fake news is made-up nonsense
delivered for financial gain CNN's
reporting was not fakes new fake news
it's journalists follow the same
standards to which other news
organizations including Fox News adhere
senior administration officials
regularly speak without attribution so
that the public can be was informed of
what our government is doing it wasn't
just Shep Smith also Brett Baier from
Fox News saying banning these outlets
from the gaggle was absolutely incorrect
if you're an administration with nothing
to hide and you run your entire campaign
on the clearly bogus but often repeated
promise of transparency banning the
media outlets that do investigative news
and aren't and then allowing the ones
that fawn over you doesn't exactly
communicate transparency we need to get
beyond the fact that everything is alive
because that's not going to change they
lied their way into office they lied
their way through a month one but this
also has another goal which is to
cultivate a sort of special relationship
with the right-wing propaganda press so
that they'll do Trump's bidding when
Trump calls they will do it no doubt and
as we learned last week it worked when
Trump staff would plant news to counter
Trump's Twitter meltdowns very dangerous
well it's good to see that the more
legitimate media sources not the
right-wing prep the propaganda machine
we are standing together with CNN and
the rest of the media outlets that were
banned some of that meeting because I
think they realized they could be the
next to go I mean if they are critical
in any way of the Trump administration
they could reach the same fate all media
outlets other than propaganda ones that
are just planning to fawn over Trump for
the next four years should be worried
about this because that line could be
drawn on one side of you or the other at
any time